[Music]
please welcome the very funny Tony day
oh thank you very much I am very excited
to be here I will tell you guys a little
about myself before I was a comedian I
was a school teacher and my favorite
story from teaching school this kid was
being expelled and his dad told me he
wasn't that worried about it because
Albert Einstein was expelled from school
- yes sir that's true that's because
Einstein was smarter than everyone else
and he couldn't handle it
your kids being expelled for flapping
his wiener out the bus window they have
taken two different pathways when I have
a day off on the road I like hanging out
in those big bookstores whenever I go in
there always running across that series
of books called for dummies and then for
everything now gardening for dummies
interior design for dummies
I saw a brand-new one I am NOT making
this up athletic scholarships for
dummies
I didn't know they came any other way I
live in New York City about a year ago
Hurricane sandy went through New York I
was traveling at the time I was watching
the news keeping up with it and on the
news they said that 38 people died that
day when the hurricane went through now
38 sounds like a big number but New
York's a giant city it made me wonder
how many people died there on a normal
day
turns out 156 hurricane sandy saved
lives
I'd take my computer into the helpdesk
at the Apple store but at the Apple
store they don't call it the helpdesk
they call it the Genius Bar it's kind of
pompous name don't you think
Genius Bar it's like sure you know more
about computers and I do but let's be
honest you work at the mall right next
to Cinnabon I've been married a while I
have a friend that's in the new
relationship though I find that to be
quite amusing
just the other day she told me when she
and her boyfriend make love time stands
still and I felt bad breaking the news
to her that if they start making love it
925 and then when it's all done she
looks at the clock and it's
still 9:25 jonny endurance did not bend
the space-time continuum although he did
travel at nearly the speed of light he
was any faster beat 9:24 when you've
been married a while they always have
these little ideas they'll think still
married couples keep the spice in their
love life the ones I can't stand they
have these little love coupon books you
know they'll be like a coupon you can
redeem with your wife for being an
intimate outside or another one for the
backseat of the car but I always feel
like such a sleazeball when I use them
cuz trust me if my wife wanted to do it
we'd be doing it we don't need to bother
ourselves with the exchange of coupons
or currency of any sort
so really when you think about it the
only time we get to use them is when
she's not interested yeah I'll be like
hey BAE nope that's too bad cuz I have a
coupon I will try to make it quick
well if you're lucky I'll make time
stand still
[Applause]
[Music]